I seek refuge in God from Satan, the accursed. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most
Merciful. About what do
you ask one another? About the
great news, concerning which they are in
disagreement. Nay, they will soon know. Nay, they will soon know. Have We not
made the earth a
bed and the mountains as pegs? And created you in pairs and made your
sleep a rest and made the
night a
covering and made the day for
livelihood and built above you seven
strong heavens and placed a shining lamp and
sent down from the rain-bearing clouds
abundant water to bring forth thereby grain and vegetation and gardens of dense foliage? Indeed, the
Day of Judgment is an appointed time. The Day the Trumpet will be blown, and you will come forth in multitudes. And
the sky will be opened, and it will be as if it were gates, and the
mountains will be moved, and they will be as if they were a mirage. Indeed, Hell has been lying in wait for the transgressors, a place of refuge. They will abide therein for ages. They will not taste therein any coolness
or
drink except scalding water and a drink, a fitting recompense. Indeed,
they did not expect
an account and denied
Our signs with vehement denial. And everything
We have recorded in a
Book. So taste, for We will not increase you except in punishment. Indeed, for the righteous is attainment: gardens and grapevines and full-breasted maidens of equal age.
And a full
cup [of wine], they will not hear therein any ill speech or
falsehood. A reward
from your Lord, a gift, a reckoning.
Lord of the heavens and the earth and that between them.
[Laughter] The Most Merciful. They will
not possess from Him [the power of speech]. On the Day when
the Spirit and
the angels stand in rows, they will not speak. They will
not
speak except for one to whom the Most Merciful permits, and he will speak what is
right. That is the Day of Truth. So whoever
wills may take a path to his Lord. Indeed, We have warned you of an
imminent punishment. On the Day when
a person will see what his hands have put forth, and the disbeliever will say, "Oh, I
wish I were dust!" In
the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. By those who draw out violently, and those who release gently, and those who glide swiftly, and those who race ahead, and those who manage affairs. On the
Day when the quaking one quakes, followed by the one that follows,
hearts on that Day will be trembling,
their eyes downcast.
They will say, "Are we to be returned
to our former state when we are crumbling bones?" They will say, "That, when it is disliked, is a loss." It will only be a single blast, and at once they will be on the surface of the earth. Has there come to you the story of Moses when his Lord called to him in the sacred valley of Tuwa, "Go to Pharaoh, for he has transgressed. Say, 'Is there anything for
you except that you
purify yourself?'"  And I will guide you to your Lord so that you may fear Him. Then He showed
him the greatest sign, but he denied and disobeyed.
Then he turned away, striving. So he gathered and called out, saying, “I am your Lord, Most High.” So God seized him for the Hereafter and the first life. Indeed, in that is a lesson for those who fear Him. Are you more difficult to create or is the heaven which He constructed? He raised its height and perfected it, and He darkened its night and brought forth its morning light. And after that He spread the earth, bringing forth from it its water and its springs. And the mountains He firmly established as provision for you and your livestock. Then when the
Great Calamity comes, the Day when man will remember
what he strove for, and Hell will be brought forth for all to see, then as for him who
transgressed and preferred the life of this world, then indeed,
Hell will be his
refuge. But as for him who feared standing before his Lord and restrained himself
from [following] his desires, then indeed,
Paradise will be his refuge. They ask you about
the Hour, when will it occur? What do you know of its
occurrence? To your Lord belongs its final destination.
You are only a warner to those who fear it. On
the Day they see it, it will be as if they had not remained [in this world] except for an afternoon or its
morning. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. He frowned and turned away
when the
blind man came to him. And what would make you know? Perhaps he  He who
purifies himself or is reminded, the reminder
will benefit him.
As for him who is
self-sufficient, you
attend to him, and you are not responsible for him unless he purifies himself.
But as for him who
comes to you striving while he fears, you are distracted from him. No! Indeed, it reminds him. So whoever
wills may remember him. In honored, exalted, purified scriptures, by the
hands of noble, righteous scribes. Killing a
man! How ungrateful he is! From what thing did He create him? From a sperm-drop He created him and proportioned him. Then He made the way easy for
him. Then He caused him to die and buried him. Then, when He wills, He will resurrect him. No! He has not yet fulfilled His purpose. So let man look at his food. Indeed, We poured down water in abundance, then We split the earth open, and caused to grow therein grain, grapes, herbage, olives, palm trees, lush gardens, fruits, and fodder—provision for you and your livestock. Then when the Deafening Blast comes—the Day when a man will flee from his brother,
his mother, his father, his wife, and his
children—for every man, that
Day, will have a matter occupying him. Some
faces, that Day, will be bright, laughing, rejoicing. And some faces, that Day, will be covered with
dust, darkened by gloom. Those are the
disbelievers, the wicked.
In the name of God  In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most
Merciful. When the sun is folded up, and the stars are dimmed, and the mountains are set in motion, and the pregnant camels are neglected, and the wild beasts are gathered together, and the seas are set ablaze, and
souls are paired, and the buried alive girl
is asked for what
sin she was killed, and the scrolls are unfolded, and
the sky
is stripped away, and Hell is kindled, and
Paradise is
brought near, then every soul will know what it has brought forth. So I swear by the retreating stars, the planets that sweep away, and
the night when it darkens, and the morning when it
breathes, that it is the word of a noble messenger, possessing
power, with the Lord of the Throne, established,
obeyed, and trustworthy. And your companion is not mad, and he is certainly on the
clear horizon. And he is not stingy with the unseen. And it is not the
word of Satan, the accursed. So where are you going? It is nothing but a
reminder to
the worlds, for whoever among you wills to be upright. And you do not will except that
God, Lord of
the worlds, wills. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. When
the sky is split open, and the stars are scattered, and the seas are made to burst forth, and the
graves are
overturned, then every soul will know what it has put forth and left behind.
O mankind, what has deceived you concerning your Lord, the
Generous, Who created you, proportioned you, and balanced you?
In whatever
form He willed, He assembled you. No! But you deny the
Recompense. And indeed, there are guardians over you.
Two noble
scribes know what
you do. Indeed, the righteous will be in
bliss, and the wicked will be in
Hell, which they will enter on the Day of Judgment, and they will not be absent from it. And what will make you know
what the Day of Judgment is? Then what will make you know what the
Day of
Judgment is? A Day when no soul will have power over another, and the command, that Day, will be entirely with
God. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Woe to
those who give less than due measure, who, when they take a measure from people, demand full measure, but when they give by
measure or weight to them, give less than due. Do they not think that they will be resurrected for a
tremendous Day, the Day when mankind will stand before the Lord of
the worlds? No! Indeed, the record of the wicked is in
Sijjin. And what will make you know what Sijjin is? A written
record.
Woe on that Day to
the deniers, who deny the Day of
Judgment. And none denies it except every transgressor and sinner.
When
Our verses are recited to him, he says, "
Legends of the
former peoples!" No! Rather, what they used to earn has covered
their hearts. No! Indeed, they will be veiled
from their Lord that Day.
Then they will be in Hell. Then it will be said, "
This is what you used to
deny." No! Indeed, the
record of the Father is in '
Illiyyun. And what will make you know what 'Illiyyun is? A written record
witnessed by
those brought near [to God]. Indeed, the righteous will be in
bliss, reclining on
couches, looking on. You will
recognize in their faces the look of the eye.
They will be given to drink of a
sealed nectar, whose seal is musk. And for this
let the
competitors compete. And its mixture is from Tasnim, a spring from which those brought near [to Allah] drink. Indeed, those who committed crimes used to
laugh at those who believed
when they passed by them, winking at one another. And when they returned
to their families, they would return jesting.
And when they saw them, they would say, "Indeed,
these are truly astray." But they were
not sent as
guardians over them. So today is the Day of those who believed,
laughing at the disbelievers, reclining on
couches, looking on. Have the
disbelievers been rewarded for what they used to
do? In the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most
Merciful. When the sky
is split open and it listens to its
Lord and is obligated [to do so]. And when the earth is stretched out and throws out what is within it and becomes empty and listens to its Lord and is obligated [to do so]. O mankind, indeed you are laboring toward your Lord with [great] exertion, and you will meet
Him. Then as for him who is given his record in his
right hand, he will be judged with an easy reckoning and will
return to his family in
joy. But as for him who is given his record
behind his back, he will cry out for
destruction and will enter a blazing Fire. Indeed, he was
among his family in
joy. Indeed, he
thought that there would be no return [to Allah]. Yes, indeed,
his Lord was ever, of him,
Seeing. So I swear by the twilight and the
night and what it envelops  And the moon, when it is full, you will surely
ascend from one stage to another. So what is the matter with them that they do not believe?
And when the Qur'an is recited to them, they do not
prostrate. Rather, those who disbelieve deny, and
Allah knows best what they
conceal. So give them tidings of a painful punishment,
except for those who believe and do righteous
deeds. For them is a reward uninterrupted.
In the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. And the
sky containing
constellations, and the
promised Day, and the witness and that which is witnessed. Cursed were the
companions of the
trench, the fire full of fuel, when they sat around it, and
they were witnesses to what they were doing to the
believers. And they were not saved from them except that they
believed in Allah, the Great, the Exalted in Might, the Praiseworthy, to Whom belongs the
dominion of the heavens and the
earth. And Allah is Witness over all things. Indeed, those who
persecute the believing men
and believing women and then do not repent will have the punishment of
Hell, and they will have the punishment of the burning fire. Indeed, those who
believe and do righteous deeds will have
gardens beneath which
rivers flow. That is the great attainment. Indeed, the punishment of your Lord is
severe. Indeed, it is He who originates and
repeats, and He is the Forgiving, the Affectionate, Owner of the
Glorious Throne, Doer of what He intends. Has there come to you the story of
the soldiers of Pharaoh and
Thamud? Rather, those who disbelieve are in
denial, and Allah is encompassing them from behind. Rather, it is a
glorious Qur'an [inscribed] in a
Preserved Tablet. In the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.  And the sky is water, and the night-
comer. And what will make you know the night-comer? It is the
piercing star. Indeed, every soul has a
guardian over it. So let
man be warned from what he was created. He was created from a fluid gushing forth,
emerging from between the backbone and the ribs. Indeed, He is able to
return him.
On the Day when
secrets will be laid bare, then he will have no power nor
helper. And the sky which returns and the earth which splits. Indeed, it is a decisive
statement, and it is not a
jest. Indeed, they are plotting a plan, and I am devising a plan. So give respite to the disbelievers. Give them respite for a little while. In the name of
God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Glorify the name of your Lord, the
Most High, Who created and proportioned, and Who determined and
guided, and Who brought forth the pasture and then made it black stubble. We will make you recite, so you will
not
forget, except what
God wills. Indeed, He knows what is declared and what is hidden. And We will ease you toward ease. So remind, if the reminder benefits. He who fears will
remember, but the most wretched
will avoid it, he who
will enter the
Great Fire, then he will neither die therein nor live. He has certainly succeeded
who
purifies himself and remembers the name of his Lord and prays.
But you prefer the worldly life, while the
Hereafter is better and more enduring. Indeed, this is
in the former scriptures, the scriptures of
Abraham and
Moses. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Has there come to you the account of
the overwhelming event?
Faces  On that Day, some faces will be humbled, toiling, weary,
entering a blazing Fire. They will be given to drink from its springs. They will have
no food
except from a
bitter, thorny plant, worthless and without any relief from
hunger. Some faces
on that Day will be radiant, their faces
pleased, in an elevated Paradise. They will not hear any idle
talk therein. Therein is a flowing spring. Therein are thrones raised high, and cups placed ready, and cushions lined up, and carpets spread out. Do
they not look at the camels, how they
were created? And at
the sky, how it was raised? And at the
mountains, how they were firmly set? And at the earth, how it was spread
out? So remind, for you are only a
reminder. You are not a
controller over them. Except for one who turns away and disbelieves, then Allah will punish him with the
greatest punishment. Indeed, to Us is their return;
then indeed, upon Us is their reckoning.
In the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. By the dawn, and the ten nights, and the even and the odd, and
the night when it departs—is there in that an oath for one of sound intellect? Have you not seen
how your Lord
dealt with 'Adim, possessor of lofty pillars, the
like of which was not created
in
the lands, and Thamud, who carved out dwellings in the rocks of the valley, and Pharaoh, possessor of stakes, who
transgressed in
the lands and increased
corruption therein? So your Lord poured upon them a scourge of
punishment. Indeed, your Lord is ever watchful. So as for
When a person is tested by his Lord, he is honored
and blessed, and he says, "My Lord has honored me."
But when he is tested by restricting his provision,
he says, "My Lord has humiliated me." No! Rather, you honor
the orphan, but you do not urge one another to
feed the
poor, and you devour inheritance, devouring it, and you
love wealth with an immense love.
When the earth is leveled, leveled, and your
Lord comes with the angels, rank upon rank, and Hell is brought forth on that Day, on that Day
man will remember, and
I will remember this. He will
say, "Oh, I wish I had sent forth
[good deeds] for my life!" On that Day, no one will punish with His punishment, and no one will bind with His binding. O tranquil soul, return to your Lord, well-pleased and pleasing [to Him], and
enter among My
servants and enter My Paradise. In the name of
God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. I
swear by this city, and you are a resident of this
city, and by the father and
what he begot. We have certainly created man in toil. Does he think that no one has power over
him? He says, "I have destroyed what was hidden." Does he think that no one sees him? Did We not give
him two
eyes, a tongue, and two lips, and show him the
two paths? But he plunged  The obstacle,
and what will make you know the obstacle? It is freeing a slave or
feeding them on a day of severe
hunger, an
orphan of
close relation or a needy person in distress.
Then he will be among those who believe and enjoin one another to
patience and enjoin one another to compassion.
Those are the companions of the
right. And those who disbelieve in
Our verses - they are the companions of the left. Upon them is a
fire
closed in. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. By the sun and its brightness, and the
moon when it
follows it, and the day when it reveals it, and the night when it covers it, and the
sky and what He
constructed, and the earth and what He spread out, and the soul and
what He proportioned, and inspired it with its wickedness and its righteousness, indeed he has succeeded who purifies it, and indeed he has failed who corrupts it. Thamud denied it when He sent the most wretched of them. So the
Messenger of God said to them, "Give her the she-camel of God and let her drink," but they denied him and hamstrung her. So
their Lord destroyed them for their
sin and leveled them. And He does
not fear the consequences thereof.
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. By the night when it grows dark, and
the day when it shines, and by Him Who
created the male
and the female.  Your striving is to tighten the reins. As for him who
gives and fears Allah and believes in the best reward, We
will ease him toward ease. But as for him who withholds and considers himself self-sufficient and denies the best reward, We will ease him toward difficulty. And his wealth will not avail him
when he
falls. Indeed, it is upon Us to guide, and indeed, to Us belongs the Hereafter and the first life. So
I have warned you of a
blazing Fire which none will enter except the most wretched, who denies and
turns away. But he who fears Allah will be spared from it, he who gives his wealth to purify himself, and no
one has with him any favor for which reward is due, except seeking the pleasure of his Lord,
the Most High. And he will soon be satisfied.
In the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. By the morning brightness and by the night when it covers with darkness, your Lord has not forsaken you,
nor has He become displeased. And the
Hereafter is better for you than the
first life. And your Lord will soon give you, and you will be satisfied. Did He not find you an orphan and give you refuge? And He found you lost and guided you. And He found you poor and enriched you. So as for
the orphan, do not oppress him. And as for the beggar, do not repel him.
And as for the favor of your Lord, speak of it.
In the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most
Merciful. We have expanded for you your breast and removed from you your burden which weighed down your back and raised you up.
Your remembrance is for you. Indeed,
with hardship comes
ease. Indeed, with hardship comes ease. So when you have finished, then stand up [for worship]. And
to your Lord direct [your] longing. In
the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. By the
fig and
the olive, and Mount Sinai, and this secure city. We have certainly
created man in the best of forms;
then We reduced him to the lowest of
the low, except for those who believe and do righteous deeds, for they will have a
reward uninterrupted. So what can make
you deny the religion after this? Is
not God the most just of
judges? In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Read in
the name of your Lord who created. Created. Created man from a clinging substance. Read, and your Lord is the Most
Generous, Who taught
by the pen, taught man that which he did not
know. No! Indeed, man transgresses when he sees himself upright. Indeed,
to your Lord is the return. Have you seen the one who forbids prayer? Have you seen
if he is on the right path or
enjoins
righteousness? Have you seen if he denies and turns away? Does he not know
that God
sees? No! If he does not desist, We will surely seize him by the forelock - a lying, sinning forelock. Then let him call upon his associates; We will call upon the angels of punishment. No! Obey him, but prostrate and
draw near [to God]. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Indeed, We
sent it down on the Night of Decree. And what will make you know the Night of
Decree?  The Night of Decree is better than a thousand months.
The angels and the Spirit descend therein by permission of their Lord for every matter.
Peace it is until the emergence of dawn. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most
Merciful. Those who disbelieved among the People of the Scripture and
the polytheists were not to be parted [from their ways] until there came to them clear proof
from God a Messenger reciting
purified scriptures containing
valuable writings. And those who were given the Scripture did not become divided until
after clear
proof had come to them. And they were not commanded except to worship God, [being]
sincere to Him in religion, inclining to truth, and to establish prayer and to give
zakah. And that is the
correct religion. Indeed, those who disbelieved among the People of the Scripture and
the polytheists will be in the fire of
Hell, abiding eternally
therein.
Those are the worst of
creatures. Indeed, those who believe and do righteous deeds -
those are the best of
creatures. Their reward
with their Lord is Gardens of Eden beneath which
rivers flow, wherein they will abide
forever, God being pleased with them and they with Him. That is for whoever fears his Lord.
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. When the earth is shaken with
its [final] earthquake and the earth discharges
its burdens and man says, "What is [wrong] with it?" - On that Day it will speak.
It will be informed that your Lord has inspired it. On that Day
people will depart separated [into groups] to be shown
their deeds. So whoever does an atom's weight of good will be rewarded.  And
whoever does an atom's weight of good will see it. And whoever does an atom's weight of good will see it. In the name of God,
the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. By the snorting chargers, striking sparks, and raiding at
dawn, raising dust and spreading it far and wide. Indeed,
man is ungrateful to his Lord, and
he is a witness to that. And indeed, he is intensely
fond of wealth. Does he not know that when the contents of the
graves are scattered and what is in the
breasts is fortified, his Lord will be fully aware of them on that Day? In the
name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most
Merciful. The Striking Calamity! What is the Striking Calamity? And what will make you know what the Striking Calamity is? On the
Day when mankind will be like
scattered moths, and the mountains will be like
carded wool. Then as for him whose scales are light,
he will be content in his life. But as for him whose
scales are light, his refuge will be the abyss. And what will make you know what it is? A blazing
Fire! In the name of
God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. The pursuit of worldly gain has distracted you
until you visited the graves. Nay, you
will soon
know. Then nay, you will soon know. Nay, if you only knew with
certainty, you would surely see
Hellfire. Then you will surely see it with the
eye of
certainty. Then you will surely
be questioned that Day
about the
blessings. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. By time, indeed,
mankind is in loss, except for those who  Believe and do
righteous deeds and enjoin one another to truth and enjoin one another to
patience. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
Woe to every slanderer and backbiter,
who amasses
wealth and counts it,
thinking that his wealth will make him immortal. No! He will surely enter the Crusher. And what will make you know the Crusher? It is
God's
fire, which rises over
the hearts. Indeed, it will be upon them, a barrier in extended columns. In
the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Have you not seen
how your Lord dealt with the companions of the elephant? Did He not
cause their plan to go astray? And He sent against them birds in flocks, striking them with stones of baked clay, and He made them like straw eaten up. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. For the accustomed security of the
Quraysh - their accustomed security in their winter
and summer journeys - let them worship the Lord of this
House, who has fed
them, [saving them] from hunger and made them safe, [saving them]
from fear. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Have
you seen the one who denies the religion? That is the one who
repels the orphan and does not encourage the feeding of the poor. So woe to those who pray, [but] are heedless
of their prayer - those who make
show
[of their deeds] and
withhold
aid. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Indeed, We have
granted you Al-Kawthar. So pray  To your Lord and sacrifice. Indeed, your enemy
is the one cut off. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
Say, "O
disbelievers, I do not worship what you worship, nor do you worship what I worship.
Nor will I worship what you have worshipped,
nor will you worship what I worship. For you is your religion, and for me is my religion." In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. When the victory of
God has come and the conquest, and you see
the people entering into the religion of God in multitudes, then exalt [Him] with
praise of your Lord
and ask forgiveness of Him. Indeed, He is ever Accepting of repentance. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. May the
hands of Abu Lahab perish, and may he perish. His wealth will not avail him, nor what he has
earned. He will [enter to] burn in a Fire
of [blazing] flame, and his wife [as well] - the carrier of firewood. Around
her neck is a rope of [twisted] palm fiber. In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful.
Say, "He is God,
the One. God, the Eternal Refuge. He neither begets nor is born, nor is there to
Him any equivalent." In
the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Say, "I seek refuge in the Lord of daybreak from the evil of that which He created and from the evil of darkness when it settles and from the evil of the blowers in knots and from the evil of an envier when he envies." In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Say, "
I seek refuge in the Lord of mankind, the King of mankind, the God of mankind, from the evil of the retreating whisperer,
who whispers in the breasts  People are from heaven,
and people are people.